tonight we hold them to their same
standard which brings us tonight to
exhibit a
and that is exposing today's hypocrisy
this
in the case of former georgia
gubernatorial candidate
stacey abrams the longtime democrat
pivotal in driving turnout in the 2020
presidential election also the senate
runoffs now
georgia's dopey governor and attorney
general it can
learn a lot from her ability to organize
on a statewide level
she herself fights for what she believes
in she works
extremely hard frankly i respect that
in 2018 abrams lost her race for
governor
and despite the fact that she lost by
well over 50
000 votes she refused to concede
she said the election was stolen she
told the voters she actually won
take a look this is not a speech of
concession
because concession means to acknowledge
an action is right
true or proper as a woman of conscience
and faith
i cannot concede that but will i say
that this
election was not tainted was not a
disinvestment and a disenfranchisement
of thousands of voters i will not say
that do you think the vote was stolen
from me the election was stolen from me
i think the election was stolen from the
people of georgia
we had this little election back in 2018
and despite the final tally
and the inauguration and the situation
we find ourselves in i do have one
very affirmative statement to make we
won
sound familiar now is that an incitement
to
insurrection to this day over two years
later abram still refuses to concede
she says democracy failed georgia that
mistakes
clearly altered the outcome of the
election she even claimed that there
were tens of thousands of examples of
voter suppression
fraud abuse and that this was not a free
and not a fair election take a look
was the election in georgia statewide a
free and fair election
it was not a free and fair election we
had thousands of georgians who were
purged from the rolls
wrongly it was not fair to the
the thousands who were forced to wait in
long lines
because they were polling places that
were under-resourced
or worse they had no polling places to
go to because more than 300 have been
closed
it was not fair to the thousands that
were put on hold with their
registrations
and it was not fair to those who filled
out absentee ballots
and depending on the county you sent it
to it either was counted or not counted
assuming you received it in time
anyone the media say she's a liar or
anyone in the media
say this was insurrection language
according to abrams she
is the rightful governor of georgia have
democrats ever accused the media ever
accused stacey abrams of inciting
insurrection
has anyone on the left even criticized
her claims
of course not now while abrams refuses
to accept the results in georgia
dozens of other top democrats also
refused
to this day to accept the results in
2016
and that includes hillary clinton
herself after her humiliating loss she
challenged the legitimacy
of the results 2017 she called donald
trump an illegitimate president
in 2019 she said she would beat him
again in 2020. take a look
i believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president
he knows he knows that there were
a bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did
as i've been telling candidates who have
come to see me
you can run the best campaign you can
even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you
i do think that he knows uh that
he's an illegitimate president and
because of that
he is he's he's very
insecure about it it wasn't on the level
it wasn't on the level
in 2016 it could be once again not on
the level
so does anyone in the democratic party
the media mob do they have a problem
with hillary clinton's rhetoric
did she incite insurrection what about
in august of last year when hillary told
joe biden
not to concede the election under any
circumstances
take a look joe biden should not concede
under any circumstances because
i think this is going to drag out and
eventually i do believe he will win if
we don't give
an inch and if we are as focused and
relentless
as the other side don't concede under
any circumstances so
are democrats going to hold her
accountable for these statements they're
going to feign their
their outrage as they always do what
about nancy pelosi
2017 speaker pelosi tweeting quote our
election was hijacked there is no
question
a few months later the corrupt
congenital compromised liar adam schiff
said
he had ample evidence that donald trump
colluded with russia to steal the
election
we all know now that was a complete lie
and a conspiracy theory
and of course just last year impeachment
manager
jamie raskin that guy he shared a
politically charged
conspiracy theory that republicans were
going to take away america's voting
rights
and civil rights in health care and
tweeting quote we must fight
oh this sounds this assault on health
care and the constitution
sounds like donald trump sounds like
what they're all outraged about
another impeachment manager you know
eric swalwell
when he's not hanging out with his
chinese spy girlfriend
he also declared he would like to fight
like hell
it's an impeachable offense to tell
americans to fight like hell
right will raskin swalwell will they now
be impeached
does that should they now recuse
themselves from making that argument
as they're trying to do in the u.s
senate
keep in mind 2017 remember the deranged
bernie sanders fan
targeting republican lawmakers on that
baseball field
remember he shot multiple people steve
scalise almost died that day in the
following days
in the lead up to the mass shooting the
gunman contacted
his congressional office 10 times with
complaints about the republican stance
on health care more recently an angry
mob of democrats
surrounded attacked senator rand paul
and his wife
after the rnc rioters showing up at
senator josh haldy's front door
where they harassed his wife and his
young baby
others targeted the home of senator
lindsey graham the home of mitch
mcconnell was targeted and vandalized
he was confronted in a restaurant in may
a massive crowd of far left agitators
attempted to breach the white house next
door they lit
historic st john's church remember that
on fire
what happened at the white house was
only one example
of what was a wave of summer violence
and riots
and that left at least 30 americans dead
injured thousands of police officers
a federal courthouse was attacked for
weeks on end
a police precinct literally burned to
the ground
others occupied businesses in dozens of
cities
looted vandalized lit ablaze
retired police captain member david dorn
he was murdered while protecting one of
those businesses in st
louis member horace lorenzo anderson jr
his father was on this show he was
murdered in the chas
chop autonomous summer of love spaghetti
pot
luck dinner zone in seattle last
summer's riots left a wake of
devastation
and most democrats most in the media
they didn't care
some even condone some supported these
so-called demonstrations they wouldn't
call them riots
they lied to our face and said oh it's
mostly peaceful
then kamala harris on top of everything
she said promoting a bail fund for
violent rioters arrested
one violent offender freed from jail
twice
just because of this fund was now
arrested for a third time
when is kamala harris going to be held
responsible when will any of the
democrats
be held responsible for the violent
rhetoric their
conspiracy theories their lies their
hoaxes
because if donald trump is now guilty of
inciting insurrection by saying the
exact same thing
as stacy abrams and hillary clinton well
there are dozens of other democrats
who should be held to the exact same
standard
in fact we noticed that during their
arguments this week the democratic
impeachment managers
you know two of which said fight like
hell
well have easily been talking about
members of their own party
watch this he was impeached
for inciting armed violence against the
government of the united states of
america
[Applause]
donald trump the president of the united
states ordered the crowd to march on
congress
and so the crowd marched go to the hill
today
get up and please get up in the face of
some congress people he made statements
lauding
and sympathizing with the
insurrectionists
everyone beware because they're not
gonna stop it is gonna they're not gonna
stop before election day in november and
they're not gonna stop
after election day his rhetoric was
dangerous and it was going
to result in deadly violence and that's
what
makes this so different the people are
going to turn on them
they're going to protest they're going
to absolutely harass them
he urged them again and again with
increasingly forceful language
to fight to stop the steal stand up and
fight for the best of who we are
and i'm prepared to fight and i know how
to fight the violence
was what he deliberately encouraged
i said no i said if we were in high
school i'd take him behind the gym and
beat the hell out of him
he didn't just tell them to fight like
hell he told them how
where and when we're going to keep
fighting and fighting and fighting for
this
he didn't stop it you've got to be ready
to throw a punch
he didn't condemn the violence when they
i will go and take trump out tonight
i will go and take trump out tonight
imagine if somebody said that about
biden let me make one thing clear we
believe that
every individual they are responsible
for their own
actions and their own decisions i did
not blame bernie sanders on this program
i went out of my way
not to blame him for the fact that one
of his supporters
was violent against those ball those
people playing on the ball
field but if the new standard is set by
the democratic party
all of the people you just heard would
be
guilty of inciting insurrection
based on their own words that they
presented today
but they'll never hold themselves
accountable ever that you can depend on
for democrats the rules don't apply to
them it's the same thing
fight fight fight fight like hell they
use the exact same words
oh uh words that could be viewed as
insurrection
they defend that also the hypocrisy is
breathtaking